what what what what what people buy the
cube
there's people buy the cube right as
soon as they move we shoot the crud out
of them hello there thanks for stopping
by on the devil are you today we have a
challenge if you'd like to come along
with us we have to try a winner game but
after killing every opponent we have to
emote straight afterwards that'll do
let's just get playing right come on
this is the one this is this is where
we're gonna get some crazy plays man
yeah bro is it it's bringing a shark
back I'm bringing this shark back yep
strike I'm dropping at the main bar oh
okay okay Sheila t-rex I'm not my first
word I'm just gonna go for a good old
loser dance because he's a streamer oh
god what is more there's so many people
there is so many people dude this is a
really good chance how's it going I got
one I shot another one
where's your friends you got it Jess
I've downed one I can see two people
I've no idea what to do myself this
doctor would I need to dance how many
things I have to work
emo whilst I was being hit by a pickaxe
oh my word Kalitta lately boy was a
streamer it wasn't when I was doing the
loser dance I feel wrong for that guy
all right I need for justice a guy in
front of me I see no weapon
I'm going for I'm still up in his mouth
go on you got this man okay something
oh my video is a mini good hit the guy
with a minigun yeah I've already got two
builds in me okay forget oh hey how do
we know anyone when you're real over
there
we got three Zac we go through it that's
alright seven kills in one spot that'll
do I'll do you okay bro I'll bring you
back to the land of the living
someone must be looking there's always
at least one team are looking I see you
know I figure there is someone in look
at smiler yeah so what's in my life and
my life alright he's dead okay rotate
not slice Lita nicely where's his
friends jello many got him was his
friend Andy coming no friend want a
clinger this dude oh I see it's friend
you said I left it alone
so well done well duh dummy
I didn't get the kill it's alright I'm
going for a 0 kill game someone's just
brain farted southeast very 3rd a little
bit
I gotta stop using that I slow offensive
they are East they're on top of the
mountain no 116 off the bunny rabbit oh
[Music]
you put up you put a putty put upon your
plane anybody else's legally on purpose
I can see you I can see little bit 28
blue I'll say what I'll shoot I'm you
can snipe him in the face
I'm up here dude look at me look at me
ladies coming forward now shoot shoot
you yeah no yeah boy I'm emoting because
because I was parked like he'll leave
not even killing I can't emo again I
love this game
yes like that you know okay it's a guy
on the hills behind herself I think no
minute oh come on I just drop my patch
sorry that didn't know well my apologies
I will take the blame for this there's a
guy with a minigun you are dead you are
so
jump dive dive now that is the best
intro ever I'm swearing in your sizing
that's going in right if we go to the
motel though I guarantee there will be
but tons of people you know by that I
mean to those on your if say oh I know
this needs yeah I love playing games
with a sneezing man right weapon there's
no weapons
there's no Redbirds please be in here no
I've got a trap it's a trap get up get
up get up I just follow you I got my I
got my single-most I'll take that thanks
mate I got loads from that oh I'll just
go I'll just go hit them with an axe
come on my axe and my axe this one yeah
yeah he isn't going this guy's dancing
outside I'm so sorry
[Music]
okay so good start I really did think
that was going to be more people oh
there's more people open this chest give
me one second all right
the 1 by U is 1 shot 1 is 1 here on top
of the Winnebago right knocked one
dancing pick the wrong ammo luckily save
me you need to save me I'll shine a
light for that guy that guy it's so well
whoa come back here there is a hidden
star they were noise what this
controller Battlestar what's that weapon
I see over there it would be a shot a a
decent one as well don't you day try and
take it it's mine it's mine use Jonathan
yeah you know what sometimes
here your piece of [ __ ] look you tumor
yeah I got builds are you gonna do about
it
alright good mind let's see our
architecture nice this is that's a
lovely erection you've got perfect it's
a bit crooked so I jump let's dive bomb
swan song mom have they already on any
left I'm stayin here I feel I feel
guilty as hell I'm staying here I'm
staying here
see how long I get sniped up ever you
please be all that loot in the sky I
mind getting your ass out of my face
please
this is wriggling samurai backside it's
all good I'll go get things he just flew
past my screen would you like to know
how much how much metal that I've
dropped some video do you want to know
how much metal that guy had 11 11
I'm coming too overkill is underrated
all right let's just jump like Batman
down the stairs and that man oh my god a
buttload see hard I'll leave you I will
leave you to have your little build
battle fight I don't like build battle
in Brooklyn on the best you know what I
will predict where you're going to go
our guarantee you'll both end up over
here
three weeks later can I get involved
please go for it so I'm just gonna kill
him there he is oh my God he's one HP
night oh my word
it's a streamer can't emote it's a real
streamer Wow
I was a guy over there over there
MLG was purple what's what people buy
the cube
there's people buy the cube on light
world we have to use the cube I'm just
taking off soon as they move in fact
[Music]
they're having a sparkle and candle in
the wind never know when the Ray said it
my word I've never seen that before that
was so cool I'm just gonna go see where
their dead bodies are backing a mom is
waiting to see the cube move off the map
I love it
yes sir all right right bom-bom-bom
take this person out quick as we can
nothing
oh no I picked the wrong boat luckily
save me save me I died must get revenge
Zachary get revenge
[Music]
no I need revenge you come down here
with that [ __ ]
[Music]
loving the language how dare he stop
this run of emote kills I'll never
forget that you let me die there whilst
I was doing my emote say something I'm
giving up on you there's a legit by East
in the storm oh the guys are paralyzed I
knew it oh I'll flank up like a fight
okay
[Music]
are you emoting which we most unabomb
okay I'm reload that I caught him oh oh
my friend say hello hello that say hello
to my little and there's my moat I'm
going whoa hey just a sec I didn't get
that kill why is this this game is just
trying to strip me of kills all right I
can slip through this so I'm all good
are they all dead yeah yeah alter the
storm as well so I didn't get any kills
I'm gonna die oh no no no I'm good I'm
good woah
why just look for them and she just walk
forwards overkill sixteen help can I
make it yes
did you seven I get out of that dog
fly-in without coming hello introduce
you to my shotgun
how did you not die boys my ears all
good Oh
one down - oh no I have to done please
don't hurt me I'm learning keep the
pressure on HP yeah she's done I will
now take the L because he's a streamer
we're just speaking of real professional
he was a streamer Wow one eternity later
he'll you can stop now okay we did it we
got one so that was the email challenge
why don't you give it to go and let us
know how you do thanks for watching I'm
Adam from Playstation grenade and that
guy I'm playing with that's Zack GG go
give him a sub will ya I'll put his info
in the description below
cheers darling see you next time
[Music]